ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
hello folks
thanks for being here
good afternoon everyone
tomorrow will mark uh
one year since i took office
it's been a year of challenges but it's
also been a year of enormous progress
we went from two million people being
vaccinated at the moment i was sworn in
to 210 million americans being fully
vaccinated today
we created six million new jobs
more jobs in one year than any time
before
unemployment dropped the unemployment
rate dropped to 3.9 percent
child poverty dropped by nearly 40
percent the biggest drop ever in
american history
new business applications grew by 30
the biggest increase ever
and for the first time in a long time
this country's working people
actually got a raise
actually got a raise people before the
bottom forty percent
saw their income go up
the most of all the cataracts we cut
health insurance premiums for millions
of american families and we just made
surprise medical bills illegal in this
country
you know those bills you get that you
don't expect after two to five thousand
dollars from the hospital beyond
what you thought you were going to have
to owe because the consultation you
weren't told was going to cost that much
no more
they're now illegal
thanks to the american rescue plan and
other actions we've taken
we've seen record job creation record
economic growth in the past year
now
thanks to the bipartisan infrastructure
bill we're about to make a record
investment in rebuilding america to take
us to be the number one
what best infrastructure in the world
well now we're way below that
we'll be creating better jobs for
millions of people modernizing our roads
our bridges our highways our ports our
airports
everything from
making clean water let removing lead
pipes
that every american turnout every
american can turn on a faucet and drink
clean water
urban and rural and suburban communities
it's going to make affordable high-speed
internet available to every american in
urban
rural and suburban areas we've never
done that before
now we are we're in the process of
getting that done
still for all this progress i know
there's a lot of frustration and fatigue
in this country
and we know why
krover 19
omicron has has now been challenging us
in a way that
it's the new enemy
but while it's caused
for concern
it's not cause for panic
we've been doing everything we can
learning and adapting as fast as we can
and preparing for a future beyond the
pandemic
all i know that after almost two years
of physical emotional and psychological
weight of this pandemic and had the
impact it's had on everyone for many of
us it's been too much to bear
we're in a very different place now
though
we have the tools
vaccines boosters masks tests pills to
save lives and keep businesses and
schools open
75
of adults are fully vaccinated
we've gone from 90 million adults with
no shots in arms last summer and down to
35 million
with no shots as of today
and we're adding about 9 million more
vaccinations each week
we're going to stick with our
vaccination efforts because vaccinations
work
so get vaccinated please
and get your booster
look
we're also increasing testing
should we have done more testing earlier
yes
but we're doing more now we've gone from
zero at home test a year ago to 375
million tests on the market in just this
month
if you buy a test of the store your
insurance will reimburse you
on top of that we're making one billion
one billion at-home tests available for
you to order and be delivered to your
home for free
just visit covettest.gov
to know how to get that free
test kit to your home in addition there
are 20 000 sites where you can get
tested in person for free now
and now
we have more treatments that people can
for people to keep people out of the
hospital than any other point in the
pandemic including life-saving
anti-viral pills
we purchased 20 million of these new
pfizer pills more than any country in
the world
and the bottom line on cover 19
is that we're in a better place than
we've been and have been thus far
clearly better than a year ago
we're not going to back
we're not going back to lockdowns we're
not going back to closing schools
schools should stay open
because the american rescue plan
we provided the states 130 billion
dollars 130 billion dollars to keep our
students and educators safe and schools
open funding for ventilation systems in
schools social distancing hygiene for
classrooms and school buses
in addition we've added another 10
billion dollars for covet 19 tests to be
able to be ministers administered at
schools
and many states and school districts
have spent this money very well
unfortunately some haven't
i encourage the states and school
districts that use the funding to
protect our children and keep our
schools open use it
the covet 19 is not going to give up and
accept things
you know it's just it's not going to go
away
immediately but i'm not going to give up
and accept things as they are now
some people may call what's happening
now the new normal
i call it a job not yet finished
it will get better
we're moving toward the time and covet
19 and won't disrupt our daily lives or
covet 19 won't be a crisis
but something to protect against and a
threat
look
we're not there yet but we will get
there
now the second challenge we're facing
are prices covet 19 has created a lot of
economic complications
including
rapid price increases across the world
economy
people see at the gas pumps the grocery
stores and elsewhere
so here's what we're going to do
a critical job in making sure that the
elevated prices don't become entrenched
rests with the federal reserve
which has a dual mandate
full employment and stable prices
the federal reserve provided
extraordinary support during the crisis
for the previous year and a half
given the strength of our economy
and the pace of recent price increases
it's appropriate as the federal chairman
chairman powell the fed chairman powell
has indicated to recalibrate the support
that is now necessary
i respect the fred the fed's
independence and i've nominated five
superb individuals to serve on the
federal board of governors
men and women
from a variety of ideological
perspectives
they're eminently qualified
historically diverse and have heard
bipartisan praise
i call the united states senate to
confirm them without any further delay
and here at the white house
and for my friends in congress the best
thing to tackle high prices
is a more productive economy
with greater capacity to deliver goods
and services to the american people
and a growing economy where folks have
more choices
and more small businesses compete and
where more goods can get to market
faster and cheaper
i've laid out a three-part plan to do
just that
first
fix the supply chain
covet 19 has had a global impact on the
economy
when a factory shuts down in one part of
the world shipments to shops and homes
and businesses all over the world are
disrupted
covet 19 has compounded that many times
over
a couple of months ago
in this very room we talked we heard
dire warnings about how the supply chain
problems could create a real crisis
around the holidays
so we acted
we brought together business and labor
and that much predicted crisis did not
occur
99 of the packages were delivered on
time
and shelves were stocked
and notwithstanding the recent storms
that have impacted many parts of our
country
the share of goods
in stock at stores is 89 now
which has barely changed from the 91
before the pandemic
i often see empty shells being shown on
television 89 percent are full
which is only a few points below what it
was before the pandemic
but our work's not done
my infrastructure law
will supercharge your effort upgrading
everything from roads and bridges
to ports and airports
railways and transit to make the economy
move faster and reduce prices for
families
second thing
my build back better plan will address
the biggest cost of working families
face every day
no other plan will do more to lower the
cost for american families
it cuts the cost for child care
many families including the people
sitting in this room if they have
children and they're working full-time
many families pay up to 14 000 a year
for child care in big cities less than
that in smaller ones
my plan cuts that in half
that will not only be a game changer for
so many families budgets but it will
mean so much
for nearly two million women who
women who've left the workforce during
the pandemic because of things like
child care
my buildback better plan cuts the price
of prescription drugs so insulin
that today costs some people as much as
a thousand dollars a month
will cost no more than 35 a month
it cuts the cost of elder care it lowers
energy's cost and it will do all this
without raising a single penny in taxes
on people making under 400 000 a year or
raising the deficit
in fact my plan cuts the deficit
and it boosts the economy
by getting more people into the
workforce
that's why 17 nobel prize winners for
economics
say will ease long-term inflationary
pressure the bottom line
if price increases are what you're
worried about
the best answer is my build back better
plan
third thing we're going to do promote
competition
look in too many industries a handful of
giant companies dominate the market in
sectors like meat processing railroad
shipping and other areas
this isn't a new issue
it's not been the reason we've had high
inflation today it's not the only reason
it's been happening for a decade
but over time it has reduced competition
squeezed out small businesses and
farmers ranchers and increased the price
for consumers
we end up with an industry like the meat
processing industry
where four big companies dominate the
markets
pay ranchers less for their cattle they
grow
charge consumers more for beef hamburger
meat whatever they're buying prices are
up look
i'm a capitalist
but capitalism without competition is
not capitalism it's exploitation
so i signed an executive order to tackle
unfair competition on our economy and
we're going to continue to enforce it
along with working with congress where
we can
a close of this
we have faced some of the biggest
challenges that we've ever faced in this
country
these past few years challenges to our
public health
challenges to our economy
but we're getting through it
and not only are we getting through it
we're laying the foundation for future
where america wins the 21st century
by creating jobs at a record pace
now we need to get inflation under
control
we have developed an extraordinarily
effective booster shots and antiviral
pills
now we need to finish the job to covert
19 under control
i've long said
it's never been a good bet to bet
against the american people or america
i believe that more than ever today
we've seen the grit determination in the
american people this past year
but the best days of this country are
still ahead of us not behind us
i'm happy to take questions
yes
thank you mr president i know some of my
colleagues will get into some specific
issues but i wanted to zoom out on your
first year in office inflation is up
uh your signature domestic legislation
is stalled in congress in a few hours
from now the senate uh an effort in the
senate to deal with voting rights and
voting
voting reform legislation is going to
fail
kova 19 is still taking the lives of
1500 americans every day
and the nation's divisions are just as
raw as they were a year ago did you over
promise to the american public what you
could achieve in your first year in
office and how do you plan to course
correct going forward why are you such
an optimist
look
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed when anybody thought would
happen
the fact of the matter is that
we're in a situation where
we have made enormous progress you
mentioned the number of deaths from
covet
well it was
three times that not long ago it's
coming down everything's changing
it's getting better
look um
i didn't over promise
but
i think if you take a look at what we've
been able to do
you'd have to acknowledge we made
enormous progress
but one of the things that i think
is something that uh
one thing i haven't been able to do so
far
is get my republican friends to get in
the game of making things better in this
country for example i was reading the
other day and i had i wrote the quote
down so i don't misquote him
a quote from senator sununu when he
decided that he wasn't going excuse me
governor sununu when he decided he
wasn't going to run for the senate in
new hampshire here's what he said
they were all for the most quote they
were all for the most part content with
the speed at which they weren't doing
anything
it was very clear that we just had to
hold the line for two years
okay
so i'm just going to
be a roadblock for the next two years
that's not what i do sununu said
he went on to say it bothered me
that they were okay with that
then he was on to say i said okay so
we're not going to get stuff done
if we win the white house back
if we win the white house back
why didn't we do anything in 2017 and
2018
and then he said how the republican
sununu spoke to answer the challenge he
said crickets yeah crickets
they had no answer
i did not anticipate that there'd be
such a stalwart effort to make sure
that the most important thing was that
president biden didn't get anything done
think about this what are republicans
for
what are they for
they need one thing they're for
and so
the problem here is that i think what's
happens what i have to do
in the in the change in
tactic if you will
i have to make clear to the american
people what we are for we passed a lot
we passed a lot of things that people
don't even understand what's all that's
in it understandably
remember when we passed the affordable
care act
and everybody thought that you know it
really was getting pummeled and beaten
and it wasn't until after out of office
and that next campaign when uh that
off-year campaign
and uh i went into a whole i wasn't in
office and we were in a whole bunch of
districts campaigning for democrats and
republican districts who said they
wanted to do away with with
health care with obamacare
and i started pointing out that if you
did that pre-existing conditions would
no longer be covered
and they said huh
we didn't know that
we didn't know that and guess what
we won over 38 seats
because we explained to the people
exactly what
in fact had passed
now one of the things that i remember
saying and i'll end this i remember
saying to
president obama when he passed the
affordable care act i said you ought to
take a victory lap
and he said there's so many things going
on we don't have time to take a victory
lap
as a consequence no one knew what the
detail of the legislation was
they don't know a lot of the detail of
what we passed so the difference is
i'm going to be out on the road a lot
making the case around the country
with my colleagues who up for
re-election and others making the case
of what we did do
and what we want to do
what we need to do
and so i don't think i've over promised
at all and i'm going to stay on this
track you know one of the things that uh
i remember and i'll end this
i was talking with uh
you know uh
jim clyburn
who was a
great help to me in the campaign in
south carolina
and jim said and when he endorsed me and
there was a there was a clip on
television the last couple days
of jim
and it said that we want to make things
accessible and affordable
for all americans
that's health care
that's education
that's
prescription drugs
that's making sure you have access
access to all the things that everybody
else has we can afford to do that we can
we can't afford not to do it
so i tell my republican friends here i
come
this is going to be about what are you
for
what are you for
and lay out what we're for
um
mary bruce abc
thank you mr president
you mentioned your republican colleagues
but right now your top two legislative
priorities your social spending package
and voting rights legislation are
stalled blocked by your own party after
months of negotiation you are only
guaranteed control of washington for one
more year before the midterms do you
need to be more realistic and scale down
these priorities in order to get
something passed
no
i don't think so when you say more
realistic i think it's extremely
realistic to say to people
because let me back up
you all
really know
the politics of this country and your
networks and others you spend a lot of
time which i'm glad you do
pulling this data determining where they
are what the american people's attitudes
are etcetera
american people overwhelmingly
agree with me on prescription drugs they
overwhelmingly agree with me on the cost
of education they overwhelmingly agree
with me on early education they
overwhelm and go on the list on on on
child care
and so
we just have to make the case what we're
for and what the other team's not for
look
we knew all along that a lot of this was
going to be an uphill fight
and one of the ways to do this is to
make sure we make the contrast as clear
as we can
and one of the things that i think is
we're going to have to do
is just make the case i don't think
there's anything unrealistic about what
we're asking i'm not trying to i'm not
asking for castles in the sky i'm asking
for practical things the american people
have been asking for for a long time
a long time
and i think we can get it done
you're not going to scale down any of
these priorities but so far that
strategy isn't working you haven't been
able to get some of these big
legislative ticket items done real big
ones done bigger than any president has
ever gotten in the first year but
currently mr president
your spending package voting rights
legislation they're not going anywhere
so that's true is there anything that
you are confident you can get signed
into law before the midterm elections
yes i'm confident we can get
pieces big chunks of the buildback
better law signed in law
and i'm confident that we can take the
case to the american people that the
people they should be voting for who are
going to oversee whether the elections
in fact are legit or not should not be
those who are being put up by the
republicans to determine to determine
that they're going to be able to change
the outcome of the election so whether
or not we can actually get election and
by the way i haven't given up we haven't
finished the vote yet on what's going on
on on the uh um on voting rights and the
john lewis bill and others but uh
um so
look this is
i i've been engaged a long time in
public policy
and i don't know many things that have
been done
in
one fell swoop
um and so i think the bet the most
important thing to do
is try to
inform not educate inform the public
of what's at stake
in stark terms and let them make
judgments and let them know who's for
them and who's to get them who's there
and who's not there and make that the
case and that's what i'm going to be
spending my time doing in this off-year
election
you mentioned republicans in reaching
out to them some republicans who may be
open to major changes on voting rights
for instance like mitt romney he says he
never even received a phone call from
this white house why not i like
look mitt romney is a straight guy he's
uh
and
one of the things that we're doing i was
trying to make sure we got everybody on
the same page in my party on this score
and i didn't call many republicans
at all
the fact is that
i do think that mitt is a serious guy i
think we can get things done i think i
predict you to get something done on the
electoral reform side of this
but
rather than judge what's going to get
done and not get done
all i can say is i'm going to continue
to make the case why it's so important
to not turn
the electoral process over to political
persons who are set up deliberately to
change the outcome of elections
[Music]
allison harris
thank you mr president speaking of
voting rights legislation if this isn't
passed do you still believe the upcoming
election will be fairly conducted and
its results will be legitimate
well it all depends on
[Music]
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
and it's one thing look
maybe i'm just
being
too much of an optimist remember how we
thought not that many people were going
to show up to vote in the middle of a
pandemic
we had the highest voter turnout in the
history of the united states of america
well
um i think if in fact no matter how hard
they make it for minorities to vote
i think you're going to see them willing
to stand in line
and and defy the attempt to keep them
from being able to vote i think you're
going to see the people we're trying to
keep from being able to show up showing
up and making the sacrifice it needs to
be made in order to change the law back
to what it should be
and
but it's going to be difficult i i make
no bones about that it's going to be
difficult but we're not there yet
we've not run out of options yet and
we'll see how this moves and on omicron
and education teachers are in result in
some revolt in so many places parents
are at odds over closing schools and
remote learning you say we're not going
to go back to closing schools you said
that just moments ago
yet they're closing in some areas what
do you say to those teachers and
principals and parents about school
closings and what can your
administration do to help make up for
learning loss for students first of all
i put in perspective the question you
asked
very few schools are closing
over 95
are still open
so you all phrase the questions when
people i don't think it's deliberate on
your part but you phrase the question of
anyone watching this on television my
god there must be all those schools must
be closing what are we going to do
95
are still open number one
number two
the idea that parents don't think it's
important for their children to be in
school
and teachers know it as well that's why
we made sure that we had the ability to
provide the funding
through the recovery act through the act
that we the the first act we passed
to be able to make sure schools were
able to be
safe
so we have new ventilation systems
available for them we have the way they
handle they scrub down the laboratories
and
i mean the laboratories kids go to to go
to the bathroom
uh cafeterias buses etc that all that
money's there there's billions of
dollars made available it's there
not every school district has used it as
well as it should be used but
it's there
and so in addition to that there is now
another 10 billion dollars for testing
of students in the schools so i i think
as time goes on
it's much more likely you're going to
see that number go back up from 95
percent back up to 98 99 percent but the
outfit
the individuals of the district that
says we're not going to be open is
always going to get and i'm not being
critical of any of you it's always going
to get front page it's always going to
be the top of the news but let's put it
in perspective
95 as high as 98 of the schools in
america are open
functioning
and capable
of doing the job
um
how about
jen epstein bloomberg
thank you mr president thank you
um
your top foreign policy advisors have
warned that russia is now ready to
attack ukraine but there's still little
unity among european allies about what a
package of sanctions against moscow
would look like
if the us and nato aren't willing to put
troops on the line to defend ukraine
american allies can't agree on a
sanctions package hasn't the u.s and the
west lost nearly all of its leverage
over vladimir putin and given how
ineffective sanctions have been in
deterring putin in the past why should
the threat of new sanctions give him
pause
well because he's never seen
sanctions like the ones i promised will
be imposed if he moves number one
number two we're in a situation where
uh vladimir putin is about to we've had
very frank discussions
uh vladimir putin and i
and
the idea that nato is not going to be
united i don't buy i've spoken to every
major nato leader
we've had the nato russian summit we've
had other the osce has met etc and so i
think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having a fight about
what to do and not do etc but if they
actually do what they're capable of
doing with the force amassed on the
border it is going to be a disaster for
russia if they further engrade you
invade ukraine and that our allies and
partners are ready to impose severe cost
and significant harm on russia and the
russian economy and you know we're going
to fortify our nato allies i told them
on the eastern flank if in fact he does
invade we're going to i've already
shipped over 600 million dollars worth
of sophisticated equipment defensive
equipment to the ukrainians the cost of
going into ukraine in terms of physical
loss of life for the russians they'll
they'll be able to prevail over time but
it's going to be heavy it's going to be
real it's going to be consequential
in addition to that putin has a you know
has
a stark choice he either de-escalation
or diplomacy a confrontation of the
consequences look i think you're going
to see
for example
everybody talks about how russia has
control over the uh the energy supply
that europe absorbs well guess what that
that that money that they earn from that
makes about 45 of the economy
i don't see that as a one-way street
they go ahead and cut it off
it's like my mother used to say you're
biting your nose off to spite your face
it's not like they have all these
wonderful choices out there
i spoke with the prime minister of
finland
and you know we're talking about
concern on the part of finland and
sweden about what russia is doing the
last thing that that russia needs is
finland deciding to change its status
they didn't say they're going to do that
but they're talking about what in fact
is going on and how outrageous russia
has been
we're finding ourselves in a position
where i believe you'll see that there'll
be severe economic consequences for
example anything that involves dollar
denominations if they make a if they
invade they're going to pay they're not
going their banks will not be able to
deal in dollars
so there's a lot's going to happen but
here's the thing
my conversation with putin and we've
been
how can we say it
we have no problem understanding one
another
he has no problem understanding me nor
me him
and
the direct the conversations were i
pointed out i said you know
you've uh occupied before
other countries but the price has been
extremely high
how long
you can go in and over time have great
loss and economic loss go in and occupy
ukraine
but
how many years
one
five ten
what what is that going to take what
toll does that take
it's real it's consequential
so this is not all just a cake walk
for russia
militarily they have overwhelming
superiority
and on on
as it relates to ukraine
but they'll pay a stiff price
immediately
near term medium term and long term if
they do it
um i'm sorry uh
okay
[Music]
david sanger new york times
thank you mr president i wanted to
follow up on your answer there uh about
russia and ukraine
when you were in geneva in june
uh you said to us uh about president
putin i think the last thing he wants
now
is a cold war
now since then of course you've seen him
gather these troops hundred thousand
troops around ukraine your secretary of
state said today he thought he could
invade it at any moment you've seen the
cyber attack
and you've seen the demand that he had a
sphere of influence in which you would
withdraw
all american troops and nuclear weapons
from what used to be the soviet bloc so
i'm wondering if you still think
that the last thing he wants is a cold
war
and has your view of him changed in the
past few months
and if it has
and he does invade would your posture be
to really move back
to the kind of containment policy that
you saw so often when you were
still in the senate
the answer is that um
i think he still does not want any
full-blown war
number one
number two do i think he'll test
the west test the united states and nato
as
as uh
significantly as he can yes i think he
will
but i think he'll pay a serious and dear
price for it that he doesn't think now
will cost him what it's going to cost
him
and i think he'll regret having done it
now
whether or not i think that
how can i say this
in a public forum
i think
that
he
is dealing with
what i believe he thinks is the most
tragic thing that's happened
to mother russia
in that
the berlin wall came down the empire has
been lost and near abroad is gone etc
the soviet union has been
split
um but think about what he has
he's eight time zones
burning tundra that will not freeze
again
naturally
a situation where he has a lot of oil
and gas
but he is trying to find his place in
the world between
china and the west
and so i'm not so sure
that
he has
david i'm not so sure he has uh
certain what he's going to do my guess
is he will move in
he has to do something and by the way
i've indicated him
the two things he said to me that he
wants guarantees on
one is
ukraine will never be part of nato
and two
that
nato or the there will not be strategic
weapons stationed in
ukraine
we can work out something on the second
piece
pretending what he does along the
russian line as well the russian border
in the european area of russia
on the first piece
we have a number of treaties
internationally and in europe that
suggests that you get to choose who you
want to be with
but the likelihood that ukraine is going
to join nato in the near term is not
very likely based on much more work they
have to do in terms of democracy and a
few other things going on there
and whether or not the major allies in
the west would vote to bring ukraine in
right now
so there's room to work if he wants to
do that but i think as usual he's going
to
i probably shouldn't go any further but
i think it will hurt him badly
it sounds like you're
offering some way out here some off-ramp
and it sounds like what it is is
at least an informal assurance that nato
is not going to
take in ukraine
anytime in the next few decades and it
sounds like you're saying we would never
put nuclear weapons there he also wants
us to move all of our nuclear weapons
out of europe and not have troops
rotating through the old soviet block do
you think there's space for the there no
no there's not space for that we won't
permanently station but the idea we're
not going to we're going to actually
increase true presence in poland and
romania et cetera if in fact he moves
because we have a sacred obligation on
article 5 to defend those countries they
are part of nato we don't have that
obligation relative to ukraine although
we have great concern about what happens
in ukraine
thank you
um
maureen
usa today
thank you mr president i want to follow
up on your comment on uh build back
better and also ask you a question about
the pandemic
you said that you're confident you can
pass big chunks of buildback better this
year does that wording mean that you are
thinking about you're looking at
breaking the package up into
individual portions
and then on the pandemic now that the
supreme court has blocked the
vaccination or test rule for larger
businesses are you can reconsidering
whether to require vaccines for domestic
flights as a way to boost vaccination
rates
uh now look uh first of all
on the
last part of the question
the supreme court decision i think was a
mistake but you still see
thousands and thousands of people who
work for major corporations having to be
tested as a consequence of the decision
made by the corporation not by the
standard i said that that is there i
think you'll see that increase not
decrease number one
what was the first part of your question
uh on your your comment that you made
that you're confident that major chunks
of build-back better can pass are you
breaking it up yes well uh it's clear to
me that uh
that we're going to have to
probably
break it up
i think that we can get and i've been
talking to
a number of my colleagues on the hill i
think it's clear that
we would be able to get support
for
the
for the 500 plus billion dollars for
energy and the environmental issues that
are there
on number one
uh number two uh
i know that uh
the two people who've opposed on the
democratic side at least
um
support a number of things that are in
there for example joe manchin strolling
supports early education three year and
four years of age strongly supports that
um there is strong support for
i think
a number of
the way in which to pay for these
uh
pay for this proposal
so i think there is i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna negotiate against myself as to
what should and shouldn't be in it but i
think we can
break the package up get as much as we
can now and come back and fight for the
rest later
um uh
ken wall street journal kent thomas
uh thank you mr president i wanted to
ask you about the economy as you said
earlier americans are feeling the
squeeze of inflation uh oil prices have
been at about a seven year high recently
how long should americans expect to face
higher prices when they're at the
grocery store when they're at the gas
pump is this something that they're
going to see into the summer into next
fall or and and separately
you talk about the importance of the fed
but isn't that an acknowledgement that
you're limited in what you can do if you
if if you're relying on the fed to make
decisions and you're unable to get a
build back better proposal through
aren't you simply limited in what you
can do to deal with inflation
well look uh as you know ken um
the inflation has everything to do with
the supply chain
and
i think what you're seeing is that
we've been able to make
progress on speeding up
the access to
materials uh for for example
one third
of the call of the
increase in cost of living is the cost
of automobiles
the reason automobiles have skyrocketed
in price is because of lack of computer
chips
so we have the capacity and we're going
to do everything in our power to do it
to become self-reliant on the computer
chips that we need
in order to be able to produce more
automobiles
that's underway we've already passed
within the context of another bill uh
money for that in the uh
in the house of representatives before
the house representatives now but i
think there's a way we can move to
if we can move to get for example that
one thing done
it can make a big difference in terms of
the cost of the total cost of
living now with regard to
[Music]
the whole issue of energy prices
that gets a little more complicated but
you saw what happened when i was able to
convince everyone from including china
india a number of other countries to
agree with us to go into their version
of the of this of their petroleum
reserve to release more into the market
so that that brought down the price
about 12 15 cents a gallon some places
some places more there's going to be a
there's going to be a reckoning along
the line here as to whether or not
we're going to continue to see oil
prices continue to go up
in ways that are going up now relative
to what is going to what impact that's
going to have on the producers
and so
it's going to be hard i think that's the
place where most middle class people
work class people get hit the most they
pull up to a pump and all of a sudden
instead of paying
two dollars and forty cents a gallon
they're paying five dollars a gallon
that's going to be really difficult but
so we're going to continue to work on
trying to increase oil supplies that are
available and i think there's ways in
which we can be of some value added in
terms of the price of gas natural gas
and the like to take the burden off the
european countries that are now totally
dependent on on russia but it's gonna be
hard it's gonna be very hard but i think
that we have to deal with for example
like i said you have a circumstance
where
people are paying more for a pound of
hamburger meat than they ever paid well
one of the reasons for that is you don't
have that many folks out there that are
the ones that are got the big four
controlling it all
and so you're gonna see more and more
we're going to move on this competition
piece to allow more and more smaller
operations to come in and be able to
engage in providing buying and providing
the access to
much cheaper
meat
than
exists now but it's going to be a haul
now and as you i assume the reason you
said if i can't get bill back better it
relates to
what those
17 nobel laureate economist said that if
in fact we could pass it it would
actually lower the impact on inflation
reduce inflation over time etc
so there's a lot we have to do
it's not going to be easy but i think we
can get it done but it's going to be
painful for a lot of people in the
meantime that's why the single best way
single best way to take the burden off
middle class and work class folks is to
pass the buildback better piece that are
things that they're paying a lot of
money for now
if you get to trade off higher gases
you're putting up with higher price of
hamburgers and gas
versus whether or not you're going to
have to you're going to be able to pay
for
education and or
child care it's alike i think most
people would make the trade their bottom
line would be better in middle class
households but it's going to be hard and
that's going to take a lot of work
oh sir
you mentioned china do you think the
time has come
to begin lifting some of the tariffs on
chinese imports or is there a need for
china to to
make due on some of its commitments in
the phase one agreement some business
groups would like you to begin raising
lifting up those uh tariffs on well i
know that and that's why my trade rep is
working on that right now the answer is
uncertain
it's uncertain i'd like to be able to be
in a position where i could say they're
meeting the commitments or more of their
commitments and be able to lift some of
it but we're not there yet
um
nancy
cbs
thank you so much mr president this
afternoon the senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell said that the midterm
elections are going to be
a report card on your progress on
inflation border security and standing
up to russia do you think that that's a
fair way to look at it and if so how do
you think that report card looks right
now
i think report cards can look pretty
good if that's where we're at but look
the idea that uh
mitch has been very clear
he knew anything to prevent biden from
being a success i i get on with mitch i
actually like mitch mcconnell we like
one another but he has one
straightforward objective
make sure that there's nothing i do
that makes me look good for the in the
mind in his mind with the public at
large and that's okay i'm a big boy i've
been here before
but the fact is that i think that the
i'm happy to debate
and have a referendum on how i handle
the economy
whether or not i've made progress on
look again
how can i i'm taking too long answering
your questions i apologize
i think that
this the fundamental question is
what's mitch for
what's he for
on immigration
what's he for
what's he proposing
to making better
what's he for
dealing with
russia
that's different than i'm proposing that
many of his republican friends or his
colleagues are supported as well
what's he for
on these things what are they for
so everything's a choice
a choice
i think
look i've laid out a proposal on
immigration that if we passed it we'd be
in a totally different place right now
we're not there because we don't have a
single republican vote my buddy john
mccain's gone
so
i mean it's it's just
it's going to take time and again i go
back to
i go back to governor sununu's quote
how long i mean a rhetorical question i
don't i know this is not fair to ask
press the question i'm not asking you
but think about
did you ever think
that one man out of office
could intimidate an entire party
where they're unwilling
to take any vote
contrary to what he thinks should be
taken
for fear of being defeated in a primary
i've had five
republican senators
talk to me
bump into me quote unquote
or sit with me
who've told me that they agree with
whatever i'm talking about for them to
do
but joe if i do it
i'm going to defeat it in a primary
we got to break that
it's got to change
and i doubt you're all i'm not it sounds
like i'm being solicitous you're all
bright as hell well-informed
more informed than any group of people
in america
but did any of you think
that you get to a point
where not a single
republican
would diverge on a major issue
not one
anyway
those five republican senators are sure
no you kidding me
i
i i maintain confidentiality
but i'm sure you've spoken to some
on voting rights sir at your first press
conference ten months ago i asked you if
there was anything you could do beyond
legislation to protect voting rights and
at that time you said yes but i'm not
going to lay out a strategy before you
and the world now
now that legislation appears to be
hopelessly stalled
can you now lay out your strategy to
protect voting rights
well i'm not prepared to do that
in detail in terms of the executive
orders i may be able to engage in and
other things i can do but one of the
things we have done
we have we have significantly beefed up
the number of enforcers in the justice
department
who are there to challenge
the these these unconstitutional efforts
in our view on constituency efforts on
the part of the republicans to stack the
election and subvert the outcomes
we have
begun to organize in ways that we didn't
before
the communities beyond the civil rights
community to make the case to the rest
of the american people what's about to
happen what will happen if in fact these
things move forward
if i had talked to you not you i'm using
you in a ptosis if i've talked to the
public
about
the whole idea of subversion of
elections by deciding who the electors
are after the fact i think people would
have looked at me like whoa i caught
talk constitutional law for 20 years a
three-credit course in separation of
powers and uh
on saturday mornings when i was a
senator and uh
i i never thought we'd get into a place
where
um
where we were talking about being able
actually
what they tried to do this last time out
send different electors
to the state legislative bodies
to represent who won the election
saying that i didn't win but
republican candidate won
i doubt anybody thought that would ever
happen
in america in the 21st century but it's
happening
and so i think i guess what i'm saying
is
nancy is that i think that
there are a number of things we can do
but i also think we will be able to get
significant pieces of the legislation if
we don't get it all now
to build to get it so that we get a big
chunk of the john lewis legislation as
well as the fair election
sir on covet if you don't mind you
touted the number of americans who are
now fully vaccinated with two shots but
even some of your own medical advisors
say that people aren't fully protected
unless they have that third shot a
booster why hasn't this white house
changed the definition of fully
vaccinated to include that third booster
shot is it because the
numbers of fully vaccinated americans
would suddenly look a lot less no it's
not that at all it's just this this has
been this has become clear and clear
and every time i speak of it i say
if you've been vaccinated get your
booster shot
everybody get the booster shot it's the
optimum protection you can have you're
protected very well with two shots if
it's the visor anyway you're protected
but you are better protected with the
booster shot
the definition right now
i'm following what the
the answer is yes get the booster shot
it's all part of the same thing you're
better protected
um
okay uh
alex alper reuters
thank you mr president um i wanted to
follow up briefly on a question asked by
uh bloomberg you said that russia would
be held accountable if it invades and it
depends on what it does it's one thing
if it's a minor incursion and we end up
having to fight about what to do and
what not to do
are you saying that a minor incursion by
russia into ukrainian territory would
not lead to the sanctions that you have
threatened or are you effectively giving
putin permission to make a small
incursion into the country
good question
um
i saw it didn't sound like didn't it
the most important thing to do
big nations can't bluff
number one number two
the idea
that we would do anything to split nato
which would be of have a profound impact
on one of
i think prominent impact on one of
putin's objectives to weaken nato would
be a big mistake
so the question is
if it's a something significantly short
of
a significant invasion or not even
significant just major military forces
coming across for example
it's one thing to determine that if they
continue
to
to use cyber efforts well we can respond
the same way with cyber
um
they have fsb people in ukraine now
trying to undermine
uh the solidarity within ukraine about
russia and to try to promote russian
interest
um
but it's very important that uh
that we keep
everyone in nato on the same page
and that's what i'm spending a lot of
time doing and there are differences
there are differences
in nato as to what countries are willing
to do
depending on what happens the degree to
which they're able to go and i want to
be clear with you
the
serious imposition of sanctions relative
to dollar transactions and other things
are things that are going to have a
negative impact on the united states
as well as a negative impact on the
economies of europe as well a
devastating impact on russia
and so i got to make sure everybody's on
the same page
as we move along
i think we will if there's something
that is that where there's russian
forces crossing the border killing
ukrainian fighters etc i think that
changes everything
but it depends on what he does it's
exactly what extent we're going to be
able to get total unity on the rush on
the
nato front if i may ask a quick one on
iran i just wanted to get your sense of
whether the vienna talks are making any
progress if you still think it's
possible to reach a deal for both sides
to resume compliance with the iran
nuclear deal or if it's time to give up
on that thank you
i'll do it in reverse it's not time to
give up
there is some progress being made
the p5 plus one is on the same page
but it remains to be seen
um
okay
kristin
nbc
um very quickly on russia i do have a
number of domestic policy issues but on
on russia very quickly it seemed like
you said that you have assessed you feel
as though he will move in has this
administration have you determined
whether president putin plans to
invade or move into ukraine as you said
look um
the only thing i'm
confident of
is that decision is totally solely
completely putin's decision
nobody else is going to make that
decision no one else is going to impact
that decision he's making that decision
and
i suspect
it matters
which side of the bet he gets up on in
the morning
as to exactly what he's going to do
and i think it is
not irrational if he wanted to to talk
about
dealing with strategic doctrine and
dealing with
forced structures in europe and in in
the european parts of russia
but
i don't know if he's decided he wants to
do that or not
so far and the three meetings we've had
go with ce anyway
have have not produced
anything because the impression i get
from my secretary of state my national
security advisor and my other senior
officials that are doing these meetings
is that
there's a question of whether the people
they're talking to know
what he's going to do
so the answer is
but based on
a number of criteria as to what he could
do for example
for him to move in and occupy the whole
country particularly from the north from
belarus it's uh he's going to have to
wait a little bit until the ground's
frozen so he can cough
to move in a direction where
he wants to talk about what's going we
we have we're continuing to provide
for defense capacities to the
to the ukrainians
we're talking about what's going on
in both the uh the baltic and the black
sea etc there's a whole range of things
that i'm sure
he's trying to calculate how quickly he
can do what he wants to do and what does
he want to do
but i he's not
he's an informed individual
and i'm sure i'm not sure i believe
he's calculating
what the immediate
short-term
and the near-term and the long-term
consequences of russia will be
and i don't think he's made up his mind
yet
i want to ask you about your domestic
agenda you've gotten a lot of questions
about voting rights mr president but i
want to ask you about black voters one
of your most loyal constituencies
i was in
congressman clyburn's district yesterday
in south carolina you opened this news
conference talking about him i spoke to
a number of black voters who fought to
get you elected and now they feel as
though you're not fighting hard enough
for them and their priorities and they
told me they see this push on voting
rights more as a last-minute pr push
than it is a legitimate effort to get
legislation passed so what do you say to
these black voters who say that you do
not have their backs as you promised on
the campaign trail i've had their back
i've had their back my entire career
i've never not had their back
and i started on the voting rights
issues long long ago that's what got me
involved in politics in the first place
and uh i think part of the problem is
look there's there's significant
disagreement
in every community on whether or not the
timing of assertions made by
people has been in the most timely way
so i'm sure that there are those who are
saying that why didn't biden
push
john lewis bill
as hard as he pushed at the last month
why did he push it six months ago as
hard as he did now
um
the fact is that
there is um
there's a timing
that is not
of one's own choice it's somewhat
dictated by events that are happening in
country and around the world as to what
the focus is
but part of the problem is as well
i have not been out in the community
nearly enough
i've been here an awful lot
i find myself in a situation where
i don't get a chance to look people in
the eye
because of both covert and
things that are happening in washington
to be able to go out and do the things
that i've always been able to do pretty
well connect with people let them take a
measure of my sincerity let them take a
measure of who i am
for example i mean as i pointed out in
south carolina
you know
last time when i was chairman of the
judiciary committee i got the voting
rights act extended for 25 years and i
got strong thurman to vote for it
that's what i've been doing my whole
career
and so the idea that i that
that i didn't either anticipate or
because
i didn't speak to it
as fervently
as they want me to earlier in the
meantime i was spending a lot of time
spent hours and hours and hours
talking with my colleagues on the
democratic side trying to get them to
agree that if in fact
this occurred if this push continued
that they would be there for john lewis
and anyway so um
but i think that's that's a problem
[Music]
that is my own making
by not communicating
as much as i should have yet
you find that uh when you deal with
members of the black caucus and others
in the united states congress i still
have very close working relationships so
it's like every community i'm sure that
there are
those in the community and i'm a big
labor guy i'm sure there's people in
labor saying why i haven't able to do a
b c or d
so it's just going to take a little bit
of time
you put vice president harris in charge
of voting rights are you satisfied with
her work
on this issue and can you guarantee do
you commit that she will be your running
mate in 2024 provided that you run again
yes and yes
do you care to expand
no there's no need to i mean i asked the
question she's gonna be my running mate
number one and number two i did put her
in charge i think she's doing a good job
let me ask you big picture particularly
when you think about voting rights and
the struggles you've had to unify your
own party
around voting rights unity was one of
your key campaign promises in fact in
your inaugural address you said your
whole soul was in bringing america
together uniting our people
people heard the speech that you gave on
voting rights in georgia recently in
which you describe those who are opposed
to you to george wallace and jefferson
davis and some people took exception to
that what do you say to those who are
offended by your speech and is this
country more unified than it was when
you first took office number one
anybody who listened to the speech
i did not say
that they were going to be a george
wallace or a bull connor i said we're
going to have a decision in history
that is going to be marked just like it
was then
you either voted on the side that didn't
make you george wallace or didn't make
you bull connor but if you did not vote
for the voting rights act back then you
were voting with those who agreed with
conor
those who agreed with
with and and so and i i think mitch did
a real good job of making it sound like
i was attacking them if you notice i
haven't attacked anybody publicly
any senator any any any any congressman
publicly
and my disagreements with them have been
made to them
communicate to them privately or in
person with them
my desire still is look
i underestimated
one very important thing
i never thought
that
the republicans like for example i said
they got very upset i said there are 16
members
of the present united states senate
who voted
to extend the voting rights act
now they got very offended by that i
want an accusation of stating a fact
what has changed
what happened
what happened
why is not a single republican
not one
that's not the republican party so
that's not an attack is the country more
unif is the country more unified than
when you first took office
uh the answer is
based on some of the stuff we've got
done i'd say yes but it's not nearly
unified as it should be look
i still contend
and i know you'll have a right to judge
me by this i still contend
that
unless you can reach consensus in a
democracy
you cannot sustain the democracy
and so this is a real test
whether or not
my
my
uh
my counterpart in china is right or not
when he says autocracies
are the only thing that are going to
prevail because democracies take too
long to make decisions and countries are
too divided
i believe we're going through one of
those inflection points in history
that occurs every several generations or
even more than that even more time than
that
where things are changing
almost regardless of any particular
policy
the world's changing
in big ways
we're going to see if you heard me say
this before we're going to see more
change
in the next 10 years we've saw in the
last 50 years
because of technology
because of fundamental alterations in
alliances that are occurring not because
of any one individual just because of
the nature of things
and so i think you're going to see
an awful lot of transition and the
question is can we keep up with it can
we maintain
the democratic institutions that we have
not just here but around the world
to be able to generate democratic
consensus on how to proceed it's going
to be hard
it's going to be hard but it requires it
requires leadership to do it and i'm not
giving up on the prospect of being able
to do that thank you
president
thank you sir
there are deep questions among americans
about the competence
of government from the messy rollout of
5g this week to the afghanistan
withdrawal to testing on covid what have
you done to restore americans faith in
the competence of government and are you
satisfied by
the view
of the competence of your government
look
let's take afghanistan i know you all
would like to focus on that which is
legitimate
we were spending
a trillion dollars a week
i mean a billion dollars a week in
afghanistan for 20 years
raise your hand if you think
anyone was going to be able to
unify
afghanistan
under one
single government
it's been the graveyard of empires for a
solid reason
it is not susceptible to unity
number one
so
the question was
do i continue
to spend
that much money per week
in the state of afghanistan
knowing that
the idea that being able to succeed
other than sending more body bags back
home is highly highly unusual
my dad used to have an expression
he said son of everything is equally
important to you nothing's important to
you
there is no way
to get out of afghanistan after 20 years
easily
not possible no matter when you did it
and i make no apologies for what i did i
have a great concern for the women and
men
who were blown up
on the line at the airport
by a terrorist attack against them
but
the military will acknowledge and i
think you will who know a lot about
foreign policy
that had we stayed and i had not pulled
those troops out we would be asked to
put somewhere between 20 and 50 000 more
troops back in
because the only reason more americans
weren't being killed than others is
because the last president signed an
agreement to get out by may the first
and so everything was copacetic
had we not got now
and the acknowledgement is we'd be
putting a lot more forces in
now am i do i feel badly
what's happening to
we as a consequence of the incompetence
of the taliban
yes i do
but i feel badly also about the fistulas
that are taking place in eastern congo
i feel badly about a whole range of
things around the world
that we can't solve every problem
and so
i don't view that as a competence issue
the issue of whether or not there's
competence in terms of whether or not
we're dealing with 5g or not
we don't deal with 5g
the fact is that you had two enterprises
two private enterprises
that had one
promoting 5g and the other one are
airlines
they're private enterprises they have
government regulation admittedly
and so what i've done
is
pushed as hard as i can
to have
5g folks hold up
and abide by what was being requested by
the airlines until they could more
modernize over the years
so that a 5g would not interfere with
the potential of the landing so any
tower any 5g tower within certain number
of miles from the airport
should not be operative
and that's and so i understand but
anything that happens that's
consequential
is viewed as the government's
responsibility i get that
am i satisfied with the way in which we
have
dealt with uh um covet and all the
things that uh that go along with that
yeah i am satisfied i think we've done
remarkably
well
you know the idea that uh
on testing we've done
we should have done it quicker but we've
done remarkable since then what we have
is we have more testing going on than
anywhere in the world
and we're going to continue to increase
that
did we have it at the moment exactly
when we should have moved and could we
have moved a month earlier yeah we could
have
with everything else that's going on i
don't view that as somehow a mark of
incompetence look think of what we did
on covet
when
uh when we were pushing on
astrazeneca to provide more vaccines
well guess what
they didn't have the machinery to be
able to do it so i physically went
to michigan stood there in a factory
with the head of the uh of uh um
astrazeneca and said we'll provide the
machinery for you this is what we'll do
we'll help you do it so you can produce
this vaccine more rapidly
i think that's pretty hands-on stuff
we also said right now
when people the hospitalizations are are
overrunning hospitals and you have docs
and nurses out because of covert they
have covert
we put thousands of people back in in
those hospitals look at all the marine
all the military personnel we have there
first responders
nobody is ever organized nobody has ever
organized
a strategic operation to get as many
shots and arms by opening clinics and
keeping and being able to get so many
people vaccinated what i'm doing now is
not just getting significant amounts of
vaccines to the rest of the world but
they now need the mechanical way is how
they get shots in arms
so we're providing them to know how to
do that
now should everybody in america know
that no i don't necessarily know that
they're just trying to figure out how to
put three squares on the table and stay
safe
but so
i i i do think the the place where
i was a little disappointed i wish we
could have written it differently
is when we did the legislation to
provide the funding for covet and the
money we provided for the states to be
able to deal with keeping schools open
some of them didn't do a very good job
some are still holding the money
i don't have the authority to do
anything about that
i think that's not particularly
competent there's things that could and
should have been done they could have
moved faster
so i um
i understand the frustration
you know i remember
i think it was i forget which cabinet
member is saying to barack obama where
something was going on
and he said well you're going to be sure
mr president
of the millions of employees you have
out there somebody's screwing up right
now
somebody's screwing up
so
you know it's just uh but i think you
have to look at things that we used to
look at on balance
what is the trajectory of the country is
it moving in the right direction now
i don't know how we can say it's not i
understand the overwhelming frustration
fear and concern
with regard to inflation
and covet i get it
but the idea if i told you
when we started i'll tell you what i'm
going to do first year i'm going to
create over 600 or 6 million jobs i'm
going to get unemployment down to 3.9
percent i'm going to generate and i
named it all you look at me like you're
nuts maybe i'm wrong
president at least in our recent memory
with this much washington experience as
you entered this office with but yet
after we sit here for more than an hour
i'm not sure i've heard you say if you
would do anything differently in the
second year of your term do you plan to
do anything differently the thing you
have to do satisfied with your team here
at the white house
i'm satisfied with the team there's
three things i'm going to do differently
now that i will now that i've gotten the
critical crises out of the way in the
sense of that moving knowing exactly
where we're going
number one i'm getting out of this place
more often
i'm going to go out and talk to the
public
i'm going to do public fora
i'm going to interface with them i'm
going to make the cases what we've
already done
why it's important and what we'll do if
what will happen if they support what
else i want to do number two
i'm bringing in more and more now that i
have time i mean literally like you it's
i'm not complaining it's you know 12 14
hours a day no complaints i really mean
it sincerely but now that certain of the
big chunks have been put in place and we
know the direction i'm also going to be
out there seeking the more advice of
experts outside from academia to
editorial writers to think tanks and i'm
bringing them in
just like i did early on bringing in
presidents and historians to get their
perspective on what we should be doing
seeking more input more information
more constructive criticism about what i
should and shouldn't be doing
and the third thing i'm going to be
doing a lot more of is being in a
situation where i'm able to
bring i'm going to be deeply involved
in the off these off your elections
we're going to be raising a lot of money
we're going to be out there making sure
that we're helping all of those
candidates and scores have already asked
me to come in and campaign with them to
go out and make the case
in plain simple language as to what it
is we've done what we want to do and why
we think it's important
how many more hours am i doing this i'm
happy to stick around
[Music]
you always ask me the nicest questions
i know you do all right none of them
make a lot of sense to me but i
well let's let's try our way come on new
year uh
why are you trying so hard
in your first year to pull the country
so far to the left
well
i'm not
i don't know what you consider to be too
far to the left if in fact we're talking
about
making sure that we had the money for
covid making sure we had the money to
put together the bipartisan
infrastructure and making sure we were
able to provide for those things that in
fact would significantly reduce the
burden on working-class people but make
them they have to continue to work hard
i don't know how that is pointed to the
left if you may recall
i you guys have been trying to convince
me that
i am uh
um
bernie sanders i'm not i like him but
i'm not bernie sanders i'm not a
socialist i'm a mainstream democrat and
i have been and mainstream democrats
have overwhelmed me if you notice
the
48
of the 50 republic democrats
supported me in the senate and virtually
everything i've asked
yes sir
a moment ago you were asked whether or
not you believed that we would have free
and fair elections in 2022 if some of
the state legislatures reforms their
voting protocols you said that it
depends
do you
do you think that
they would in any way be illegitimate
oh yeah i think it's easy to
be illegitimate imagine
imagine if in fact trump has succeeded
in convincing pence to
not count the votes
imagine if
in regards to 2022 sir 2022 i mean
imagine if those uh attempts to say that
uh
the count was not legit
you have to recount it and we're not
going to count we're going to discard
the following votes i mean sure
it i'm not saying it's going to be legit
it's the increase in the prospect of
being illegitimate is the direct
proportion of us not being able to get
these
these reforms passed but i don't think
you're going to see you're not going to
see me and i don't think you're going to
see the democratic party give up on can
go coming back at assuming that the
attempt fails today
one more sir um
you know you talk you campaigned and you
ran on a return to civility and i know
that you dispute the characterization
that you called folks who would oppose
those voting bills um as being bull
connor or george wallace but you said
that they would be sort of in the same
camp no i didn't say that look what i
said go back and read what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
so did you expect that that would work
with senators mansion or or cinema
no here's the thing there's certain
things that are so consequential you
have to speak from your heart as well as
your head
i was speaking out
forcefully on what i think to be at
stake
that's what it is and by the way
no one
no one forgets who was on the side of
king
or verse on or bull connor
no one not done the history books will
noted when i was making the case don't
think this is a freebie
you don't get to vote this way and then
somehow it goes away this will be stick
with you the rest of your career and
long after you're gone
and mr president
so i'm more on your ukraine
okay
we've only gone an hour and 20 minutes
i'll keep going but i'm i got what i'm
gonna go let me get let me get something
straight here
how long are you guys ready to go you
want to go for another hour two
okay
i'm gonna go i tell you what folks
uh
i'm gonna go another 20 minutes a
quarter of okay
yes sir
[Music]
i want to thank my communication staff
for the great help here
well uh president biden on the
coronavirus uh we're uh tragically
approaching nearly one million americans
who died
um and i'd like to ask you um why it is
during your three and a half hour
virtual summit in november with the
chinese president you didn't press for
transparency and also whether that has
anything to do with your son's
involvement in an investment firm
controlled by chinese state-owned
entities
the answer is that we did i did raise
the question of transparency i spent a
lot of time with him
and he uh the fact is that they're just
not they're just not being transparent
transparency on the crotovirus origins
and
you did during the virtual summit is
there a reason your press staff was
unaware of that
and what did you say to the chinese
president and they weren't with me the
entire time look i
made it clear that i thought that china
had an obligation to be more forthcoming
on exactly what the source of the virus
was and where it came from
yes
mr president i would like to ask you
about foreign policy
one of the first priority uh that you
declared when you came to office was to
end the war in yemen the catastrophic
war in yemen uh you appointed a special
envoy today one of your allies united
arab emirates is asking your
administration to put back the houthi
rebels or militias back on the terror
list are you going to do that and how
are you going to end the war in yemen
sir
the answer is
it's under consideration and
ending the war in yemen takes the two
parties to be involved to do it
and it's going to be very difficult
thank you very much for this honor james
rosen with newsmax i'd like to um i'd
like to raise a delicate
subject
but with utmost respect for your life
accomplishments and the high office you
hold
a poll released this morning
by politico morning consult
found
49 percent of registered voters
disagreeing with the statement
joe biden is mentally fit
not even a majority of democrats who
responded
uh strongly affirmed that statement
well let you all make the judgment
correct well so the question i have for
you sir if you'd let me finish
is why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you
i have no idea
yes sir
uh thanks mr president i appreciate it
um i i wanted to sort of address or ask
about attention that's always been in
this in this press conference on
unifying the country because you
campaigned on two things one of them is
being able to accomplish big things and
the other is the ability to unify the
country and even today you've talked
about sort of a different posture with
republicans and i i wonder if if you
still think it's possible to do both of
those things
we have to
we have to i mean
as long as i hold public office i'm
going to continue to attempt to do both
things one more follow-up um
around this time last year when you were
campaigning in georgia i think one of
the things you told people was the power
is literally in your hands you know if
if voters give democrats the house and
the senate and the presidency that all
these big things can get accomplished
and you know we've seen stalemate we've
seen things being stymied um
why should folks believe you this time
around can you think of any other
president's done as much in one year
name one for me
i'm asking you
i'm serious
you guys talk about how nothing's
happened
i don't think there's been much
on any incoming president's plate that's
been a bigger menu than the plate i had
given to me i'm not complaining
do that running in
and the fact of the matter is we got an
awful lot done
an awful lot done
and there's more to get done but look
let's let me ask a rhetorical question
no i will anyway
thank you
be yes don't get hurt no no i'm i'm
gonna take care
uh mr president thank you sebastian
smith from afp another question on
ukraine
uh ukraine borders for nato member
countries
how can certain are you concerned uh
that
a real conflagration in ukraine if the
russians really go in there
that it could suck in
nato countries that are on the border
and you end up with an actual
nato-russia confrontation of some kind
and secondly
are you entertaining the thought of a
summit with
vladimir putin as a way to perhaps try
and put this whole thing to bed address
and they've got a better way out of this
the last part last question yes when we
talked about whether or not we faced
three meetings we talked about
and we talked about we would go from
there if there was reason to to go to a
summit we talked about a summit as being
before the ukraine
item came up in terms of strategic
doctrine and what the strategic
relationship would be
so i still think that is a possibility
number one number two i am very
concerned
i'm very concerned that this could end
up being
look
the only war that's worse than one
that's intended is one that's
unintended and what i'm concerned about
is this could get out of hand
very easily get out of hand because of
what you said the borders of the of
ukraine and what russia may or may not
do
i am hoping that
vladimir putin understands that he is
short of a full-blown nuclear war he's
not in a very good position to dominate
the world
and so i don't think he thinks that but
it is a concern
and that's why we have to be very
careful about how we move forward and
make it clear to him
that there are there are pressures to
pay
that could in fact cost his country an
awful lot but i of course you have to be
concerned when you have
you know uh
nuclear power
invading this if he invades
it hasn't happened since world war ii
this is the most consequential thing
that's happened
in the world in terms of war and peace
since world war ii
yes
nearly two years have passed since the
beginning of the global coronavirus
outbreak and you again today acknowledge
that americans are frustrated and
they're tired based on your
conversations with your health advisors
what type of restrictions do you imagine
being on americans this time next year
and what does the new normal look like
for social gatherings and travel to you
well the answer is
i hope the new normal will be that we
don't have still have
30 some million people not vaccinated i
hope the new normal is people have seen
and what their own interest is and have
taken advantage of the of what we have
available to us number two
with the pill that is a problem that
appears to be as
efficacious as it
seems to be
that you're going to be able to deal
with
this virus in a way that after the fact
you have an ability to make sure you
don't get self you don't get very sick
number three um i would hope that what
happens is the rest of the world does
what i'm doing and provides significant
amounts of the vaccine to the rest of
the world
because it's not sufficient that we just
have this country
not have the virus or be able to control
the virus but that it can't pull the
wall high enough to keep a new variant
out so it requires
one of the things that i want to do and
we're we're contemplating figuring out
how to do not we are contemplating how
to get done and that is how do we move
in a direction
where the world itself
is vaccinated it's not enough
just to vaccinate 340 million fully
vaccinate 340 million people in the
united states
that's not enough
it's not enough to do it here we have to
do it and we have to do a lot more than
we're doing now and that's why we have
continued to keep the commitment of
providing vaccines and available
cures for the rest of the world as well
if i could sir and i should have said
this before francesca chambers mcclatchy
how do you plan to win back moderates
and independents who cast a ballot for
you in 2020 but polls indicate aren't
happy with the way you're doing your job
now i don't believe the polls
well why don't you just go down the road
thank you mr president uh follow up on
some of the questions about the
vaccination program you've given dozens
of speeches this year urging americans
to get vaccinated you've talked to
reluctant republicans you've said it's
people's patriotic duty there have been
very few mentions of the fact that young
children under the age of five still in
the third year of this pandemic in this
country
don't have access to the vaccine can you
speak to frustrated parents a little bit
about why that continues to be the case
and when that might change because the
science hasn't reached the point where
they're convinced that in fact it is
safe so that's what they're doing now
you could have asked me that i got asked
that question about three months ago
about people between the ages of you
know seven and 12. well it finally they
got to the point where they felt secure
in the number of tests they had done and
the test they had run that it was safe
so it will come it will come but i can't
i'm not a scientist i can't tell you
when but it is really very important
that we get that next piece
one more follow-up on buildback better
when you said it's going to likely be
broken up into chunks you mentioned that
the climate pieces seem to have broad
support you mentioned senator manchin is
a as a supporter of
early child care you left out the child
tax credit and i wonder if it's fair to
read between the lines and assume that
that is a piece given senator manchin's
opposition to it that the extension of
that is likely one of those components
that may have to wait uh until sometimes
really big components that i feel
strongly about that i'm not sure i can
get in the package
one is the child care tax credit
the other is
help for
cost of community colleges
they are massive things that i've run on
i care a great deal about i'm going to
keep coming back at whatever four i get
to be able to try to get chunks or all
of that done
yes sir the next man next to you left
thank you mr president my name is pedro
rojo sabot univision national news
ah this is actually my first press
conference here as a good to meet you in
person we always have a long press
conference awesome
awesome
i got a couple of questions for you
number one uh you said that you want to
convey your message by getting out there
in the country i wonder if you're
planning on traveling also to south
america and other countries in the in
the western hemisphere
given the fact that china has has gained
a lot of influence in the region
and the second question is
what will be your message for residents
in this country that are struggling
every time they go to the gas station
every time they go to the grocery store
and see the prices going high
and the pharmacy i happen to come from
south texas where i saw a lot of a lot
of people struggling financially in the
last few months
and so i think you
i wonder what is the message you want to
spread to them
well i try to express i've asked i tried
to answer that seven different ways
today about how to deal with inflation
um but let me answer the first question
i spend a lot of time in south america
in latin america when i was vice
president i spent the bulk of my eight
years basically in europe and or
in
latin america i'm in contact with the
leaders of the countries in south
america we're working closely
with making sure that we do everything
for example
with the uh to deal with
helping
the countries in question particularly
those in central america to be able to
help them with their ability to deal
with
the inter
people don't sit around in
guatemala and say i got a great idea
let's sell everything we have give the
money to a to a
coyote take us across a terribly
dangerous trip up through central
america and up through mexico and drop
us sneakers across the border drop us in
the desert won't that be fun
people leave because they have real
problems and one of the things i've done
when i was a vice president got support
with although i don't have much
republican support anymore is provide
billions of dollars to be able to say to
those countries
why are people leaving and how are you
going to reform your own system
and that's we've worked on a long time
it still needs a lot more work
and we're focusing on that i also
believe i've spent a lot of time
talking about and dealing with policy
having to do with maduro who is a little
more than a dictator right now
and the same thing in chile and afghani
and not the same thing but with chile as
well as argentina so look i've made a
speech a while ago when i was vice
president
saying that
if we were smart
we have an opportunity to make the
western
hemisphere a
united not united a democratic
hemisphere
and we were moving in the right
direction
under our in the last administration the
obama abide administration
but so much damage was done as a
consequence of the foreign policy
decisions the last president made
in
latin america central america and south
america
that
we now have when i call for a summit of
the democracies
i call that and a number of nations
showed up for this summit of democracy
what is it that's going to allow us
to generate we've actually had a
reduction in the number of democracies
in the world
and it seems to me there's nothing more
important we used to talk about
when i was a kid in college about
america's backyard it's not america's
backyard
said everything south of the mexican
border is america's front yard
and we're equal people we don't dictate
what happens in any other part of that
of this continent or the south american
continent we have to work very hard on
it but the trouble is we're having great
difficulty making up for the mistakes
have been made the last four years and
it's going to take some time
yes send them on the back
and then i'll go to this side okay
thank you mr president alexander
nazarian yahoo news
and thank you for holding this press
conference i hope there's more of them
um
anytime you have extra three hours we
can do it
we'll stay for a couple more um
you said you were surprised by
republican obstruction of your agenda
but didn't the gop take exactly the same
tactic when you were vice president to
barack obama so
why did you think they would treat you
any differently than they treated him
first of all they weren't nearly as
obstructionist as they are now
number one
they stated that
but you had a number of republicans we
work with closely
from john mccain i mean a number of
republicans we work closely with
even back in those days lindsey graham
um and so
the difference here is
there seems to be a desire
to work with and i didn't say my agenda
i'm saying what are they for what what
is their agenda
they had an agenda
back in the administration
when the eight years we were president
vice president
but i don't know what their agenda is
now
what is it the american public is
outraged about the tax structure we have
in america what are they proposing to do
about it anything
have you heard anything
i mean anything i haven't heard anything
the american public is outraged about
the fact that we're
the the the the state of the environment
the vast majority of the public what
have they done to do anything to
ameliorate
the climate change that's occurring
other than to deny it exist so what i'm
saying is the difference between then
and now is not only the announcement
that was made anything to stop barack
obama i get that part
but what eventually happened
we were able to get some things done we
were able to work through some things on
the stuff that was really consequential
in terms of ideologically divisive it
was a real fight
but so
but i don't think there's a time when i
i mean i wonder what would be the
republican platform right now
what do you think what do you think
their position on taxes are
what do you think their position on
on human rights
i think their position is on
whether or not uh
we should uh on the what we should do
about the cost of prescription drugs
what do you think i mean i i just
i honestly don't know what they're for
yet i know a lot of these senators and
congressmen and i know they do have
things they want to support
whether there's things i want or not
but you don't hear much about that
and every once in a while when you hear
something where there's a consensus
it's important but a small item and it
doesn't get much coverage at all
where it occurs i'm not mean coverage i
mean there's not much discussion about
it
so i just think it's a different
and i i don't know
that um
no matter how strongly
one supports the republican and or
supports
the president of the former president
united states
i don't know how we can't look at
what happened on
january 6th and think that's
that's a problem
that's a real problem
one one more question uh mr president um
by the way it's a quarter of guys now so
i'm going to do this just let's if you
ask me easy questions i'll give you
quick answers oh there's an increasing
concern i think among some democrats
that
even if schools do continue to open and
i get that most of them are now open
republicans will
weaponize this narrative of you
of you and other leading democrats
allowing them to stay closed
in the midterms next year
and you know obviously that issue has a
lot of traction with
suburban parents um as i think
i'm confused by the question i'm sorry
well that could school
reopenings or closures become a potent
midterm issue for republicans to win
back the suburbs
oh i think it could be but i hope we got
that
that
look
maybe i'm kidding myself
but as time goes on
the voter
who
is just trying to figure out as i said
how to take care of their family put
three squares on the table stay safe be
able to pay their mortgage or their rent
etc
uh has is becoming
much more informed on
the um
the motives of
um
some of the political
players
and some of the
and the political parties
and i think that
they are not going to be as susceptible
to believing
some of the outlandish things that have
been said
and continue to be said
you know
every
every president not necessarily in the
first 12 months but every president the
first couple years
most every president excuse me of the
last president at least four of them
have had
polling numbers that are 44
favorable so it's this idea that but you
all not you all but now it is well
biden's it
one poll showed him at 33
the average is 44
44 45 percent one poll i'm at 49
i mean
the idea that um
the american public are trying to
sift their way through
what's real and what's and what's fake
and i don't think
as uh
i've never seen a time
when
the political coverage
the choice of what political coverage
the voter looks to
has as much impact on what they believe
they go to get reinforced
in their views
whether it's
msnbc or whether it's fox or what i mean
and one of the things i find fascinating
that's happening and you all are dealing
with it every day and it will impact on
on how things move
is that
a lot of the speculation and the polling
data shows
that
the um
[Music]
that the
cables are
heading
south
they're losing viewership
you know
well
fox is okay for a while but it's not
gaining and a lot of the rest are
predicted to be
not very much in the in the mix
in the next four to five years i don't
know if that's true or not but i do know
that we have sort of uh
put everybody in put themselves in
certain alleys
and they've decided that
you know
how many people
who watch msnbc also watch fox other
politicians trying to find out what's
going on in both places
how many people
again i'm no expert in any of this but
the fact is
i think you have to acknowledge that
what gets covered now
is
necessarily a little bit different
than what gets covered in the past
i've had a couple
washingtonians
but the nature
not
the nature of the way
things get covered
as in my observation over the years i've
been involved in public life changed
and it's changed because of everything
from a thing called the internet
has changed because of the way in which
we have self-identified
perspectives based on what channel you
turn on
what what what network you look at that
network what what cable you look at
and it's um
it's never quite been like that
anyway
on on behalf of the correspondents
association thank you very much for
for standing for our questions we hope
the public has found it as enlightening
as uh those of us in the room have i
want to ask you sir about one of the
overviews
we appreciate it we we very much do so
uh the question i want to ask you guys
to accountability sir uh on one of the
top public concerns of course which is
the coronavirus and the government's
response to it whether it's
confusion over what style of mask to
wear
when to test how to test where to test
you know the the public is confused sir
and you see that in in the drop-off in
the polling on this question
why did you tell jeff that you were
satisfied with your team
why are you not willing to make or
interested in making any changes either
at the cdc or other agencies given the
fact that the messages have been so
confusing well first of all the message
is to the extent they've been confusing
is because the scientists they're
learning more
they're learning more about what's
needed and what's not needed
and so
the fact is that the one piece that has
gotten a lot of intention is the
the
the communications capacity of the cdc
well she came along and said look i'm
not afraid i mean i'm a scientist
and i'm learning
i'm learning how to deal with
stating what is the case that we've
observed
but look i think that it's a little bit
like saying
when we went through the whole issue of
how to deal with polio in the polio
shots
what was said in the beginning was oh no
it's changed a little bit we moved this
way that way or when we dealt with
anything else i mean
uh
as
this was a brand new
[Music]
virus a brand new phenomenon
some of it was deadly otherwise more
communicable
this is this is an unfolding story
it's a nature of the way diseases spread
we're going to learn about it in a lot
of other areas just not just covet 19.
and so
i think you know i look at it this way
think about
how astounding it was within the time
frames it took
to be able to come up with a vaccine
you used to write about that
pretty amazing
how rapidly they came up with a vaccine
that saved hundreds of thousands of
lives
did everything get right no
and by the way the idea whether we
anyway i'm
talking too much thank you mr president
i have two really simple questions
i promise
you campaigned on cancelling ten
thousand dollars in student loans do you
still plan to do so and when and then my
second question is now that you've
clarified the bull connor comments do
you plan to reach out to republicans
like mitt romney to talk about reforming
the electoral count act
yes i'm happy to speak out i've i've met
with rip i've talked to mitt on other
occasions and by the way i reached out
to the
the minority leader as well at the time
this that he they made a speech
and so
[Music]
i have no reluctance
to reach out to any republican
and anyone who and i've made it clear
look i've now had the opportunity to
travel
because of
funerals and eulogies i've made in
attendance and congressmen and senators
who've come along with me
i don't don't hold me to the number but
somewhere between 20 and 25 senators and
congresspersons have traveled with me
and i find you should get the list of
them and ask what how we i you know set
for the two three four five hours that
we've flown together sit back in the in
that conference table talk to them ask
them questions they ask me questions i
learn a heck of a lot
but as president you don't quite have
that ability to do that as often as i'd
like to be able to do it
and one of the things that i do think
that has been made clear to me speaking
of polling
is the public doesn't want me to be the
president senator
they want me to be the president and let
senators be senators
and so
if i've made i've made many mistakes i'm
sure if i've made a mistake i'm used to
negotiating to get things done and i've
been
in the past relatively successful at it
in the united states senate even as vice
president
but i think that role as president is
is a different role folks
it is now uh almost six with with all
due respect i'm gonna see you next
conference okay thank you
thank you mr president
i like them